it's so nice to see you J because at a
time like this it's very hard to connect
with people and it's it's a time where
we kind of reflect on what's going on so
here's a loaded question how are you I'm
good you know I'm just trying to make
the best of everything and I'm in
fortunate circumstances I'm surrounded
by you know people I love and everyone's
everyone's in good health
so yeah I'm good that's good is your
puppy there you have a puppy right I do
yeah he's he's out on a walk right now
with my girlfriend yeah she took him out
Rupert that's no kind of painting of him
up there that someone did to your
backgrounds blurts I can't see it that's
so cute so he keep he's keeping you uh
you know he's keeping you company which
is so nice to see I can't not having a
dog this time it's it's meant the world
to me so I love that and there's so much
to celebrate in terms of your show it's
so great that the order is being picked
up for season two and it's done a
hundred percent on Rotten Tomatoes which
is very difficult to do why do you think
fans are so absorbed into the show I
think like ends the die-hard fans that
love it is because it it's a nice genre
piece it's got everything it's got
fantasy it's got [ __ ] it's got comedy
it's got some action and I just think
the writing is amazing like then the
show creator Shelley Eriksen one of the
producers and writers they do an amazing
job at creating this this world that
everyone can kind of dive into mm-hm and
when you talk about this world do you
believe in magic do you think there's
more something out there when you're
creating a show you're involved it and
yeah before your like out whatever but
when you see the essence of this show do
you feel there is a magic out there
I do yeah like I'm a I believe there's
like magic like in in different terms
like I believe in like moments that are
kind of like magic or magic kind of
situations and so I like to believe that
you can kind of create that magic like
with people and and with yourself so but
yeah I mean especially on the show like
you're on these sets and using these
that are so real they've done such a
good job that it makes it very easy to
fly into that world and kind of just
have fun and let loose and werewolves is
that something wearable thing as much I
love it though it's just like a fun fun
narrative to have and and I love buying
into that like make-believe and and
doing stories like that all right are
you a fan of sci-fi in general I mean I
am yeah like I was a big Lord of the
Rings fan and you know Harry Potter like
all those type of types of things so I
love when you can kind of leave this
world and go to a different one that's
like full of magic and fun different
stuff when we at the end of season 1 we
see the relationship between Alyssa and
Jack kind of fall apart do you think
that relationship will pick up again in
season 2 or do you want it to have that
love relationship happening I mean it
definitely does it's a little kind of
tense and complicated which I guess is
reflective of any kind of serious
relationship but I think they want to be
together but they're just they're caught
in different worlds and they have this
drug try and make it make it work these
two characters you know they have this
affection for each other and and that
they want to to make things work but
they're they're part of different worlds
a part of different societies and it
seems no matter how hard they try they
just can't make it work but season two
is yeah it's an interesting development
for that because they kind of get caught
questioning each other's morals and what
they believe in interesting so what can
you tell us about season 2 going forward
for Jack I can tell you that you know
Jack he has to question what he believes
in kind of everything that he learned in
season one he's not sure if it's correct
anymore and you know he gets caught up
in a whole different world of like magic
in different societies and there's a lot
of great new characters that he gets um
intertwined with and we have some
amazing like guest star cameos from some
known actors that I think the fans were
really
but it's a wild ride season two is crazy
season one kind of lays the foundation
but season two is like it's kind of nuts
and the best way possible
he note about love of us he's the one we
get introduced to memory loss powder and
I'm like wouldn't that be great to have
in your life it's dangerous come like
like they say what power becomes like
you have to have a lot of
responsibilities and so but yeah
sometimes I like to hit myself with that
amnesia dust yeah would you is there any
situation where you would use memory
loss powder I was thinking about that
we're on someone else I'd like to say
that I would probably not I got to just
live with live with what I've I've done
and and his take take ownership of it so
but it would be interesting if we had it
I think my husband once in a while yeah
it's not thing would you have like
repeated takes of dust being blown in
your ear face act like you don't expect
it and snowing in your eyes and you're
kind of breathing it in and then they
got to come and dust you off and I got
to do it again so saved when those those
scenes were over for people who haven't
seen season one and a lot of people are
binge watching shows right now how would
you describe the journey fans would go
through watching season one I think it's
just it's fun like the characters are
super fun to to learn about and and and
it's like an adventure it's like a ride
so if you if you like kind of
transporting yourself to another world
and getting that escapism then yeah
you're in for like a treat a fun ride
mm-hmm and you're also working on
another project infamous with Bella
Thorne and you you play a bad guy so is
he a bad guy is he I mean he's just he's
done some bad things but he's trying to
do right he's you know he's conflicted
and he's just met this girl that he's
kind of enamored by and you know I think
just some things that uh he's just he's
not too smart but yeah he's he has good
intentions and trying to fly right but
doesn't always work
it's complicated in how I wasn't working
with Bella Thorne we haven't seen her
phone set with her how was that I was a
tree fellas amazing she's a wonderful
passionate human being she's incredibly
hard-working very focused and the whole
process of working with her and Josh the
writer and director was just so much fun
we all banded together and we're really
committed to making like the best film
we could and yeah I'd be happy to work
with either them again you know at a
time like this especially for artists
it's difficult to stay still you know
you're consistently moving you're
creating and at a time like this what
have you learned about yourself through
this process well I've learned that it's
good to have these moments of of
stillness like you say we are normally
so busy and used to this fast-paced life
but um I think it's a good time to
reflect and and just learn more about
ourselves and about our partners and our
family and there's a lot of benefits to
it so that we can kind of recharge and
get back out there we can be like in
full spirit and and full just readiness
to kind of like live and do our best
work well what do you miss the most just
hanging out with friends and family that
I love being surrounded by like a big
group of friends and just kind of
hanging out and I'm I miss being on set
like I love it again it's like a big
family eclectic mix of personalities and
funny people and yeah I really missed
that before - getting back to it one day
are you binge watching any shows just
finished watching the last dance Michael
that was amazing
and I just finished watching Sherlock
which is like the BBC show with Benedict
Cumberbatch and Martin Freeman but it's
on Netflix here so I just finished that
I loved it I could I could almost
rewatch it again yeah my kids are
consistently watching fuller house right
now so we're going back to the house and
then watch your house it's interesting
it's an interesting time to go back to
old sitcoms in television right now but
I'm so glad that you're doing okay at
and you have your family with you and
I'm looking forward to the order season
2 and of course infamous so thank you
for talking with us today really
appreciate it
it was great